hey what up there friends so this right
here is an exercise that I've taught
many many times in my career as a way of
arranging stalls in such a way that
they're kind of easy to work with in a
systematized fashion but more recently
I've also been using this as an exercise
to kind of get people uh using their
stalls more as a musical tool and I want
to show you
how
Drex here from Drex Factor po sharing
with you the love of Po spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today I'm going to be sharing with
you a very special POI dance drill that
I have been finding is super useful for
getting me moving in time with the music
sooner rather than later but before we
dive in I just want to give a quick
shout out to the Friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling pyroar
light toys spinballs and Ultra poy for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non-b buus friend of the channel Becca
Becken thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission so if you have been following me
for any length of time you know that I
really enjoy using po stalls as way to
Accent the beat of Whatever music that I
happen to be listening to I first picked
this habit up from G and I think that it
is one of my favorite things about my
own style but it's also something I
sometimes have a difficult time teaching
other people but I now have a new drill
that I've been using to kind of wake up
my body and get it used to performing
these stalls in time with the music that
I'd love to share with all of you all
right so the first step is going to be
to review an exercise that I like to
refer to as the stall boox this is
basically just a systematic way that I
found to drill all stalls and to explain
what's actually going on when we do
perform POI stalls here's what it
consists of so as you spin your PO in
wall plane like so you want to imagine
that the path that the poy head is
following is basically just a circle
directly in front of you and that that
circle is set inside of a square now
you'll note that there are four points
where the square and the circle touch
each other that's going to be where
you're going to go ahead and depart from
the circle and perform a stall so
when I want to create a stall I'm going
to wait for that point where the POI is
passing through one of those Junction
points between the circle and the square
and I'm actually going to have my hand
reach out to that uh intersection and
what's going to happen then is my poad
is going to go straight along the side
of the Box until it reaches one of the
corners this is a stall so what it winds
up looking like is this as my poad
passes through that intersection boom I
reach my hand out and the PO head drops
and this allows the POI to stall in such
a way that it comes to a complete stop
likewise this works whether we're doing
our up stalls whether we're doing our
bottom stalls and yes even if we're
doing those tricky top stalls along the
top of the box here this is part of the
reason I love this drill is it's such a
good way of visualizing and talking
about how exactly we nail those perfect
stalls where we get the PO to come to a
complete stop in each corner and also
too if you want a more deta explanation
for this drill I will include a link to
a video I did uh specifically on this
drill down in the description as well as
up in the cards uh because it turns out
to be really really useful all right so
we've got the stall box down now what do
we do with it well what if I told you
that there's a way to do this drill that
is actually going to help you nail all
those stalls on the Beat of the Music
Oho all right so our next step is that
you're going to pick out a piece of
music that has a regular and very very
very audible beat to it and you're going
to prac practice performing each of
those stalls to that beat so I'll show
you how this works I already have a song
picked out
here queued
up that I'm going to go ahead and
[Music]
start 5
6 5 6 7 eight we go boom boom boom boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
huh and we go back the other
[Music]
way crazy huh so yeah this may require
you to do some stalls a bit faster than
you may like but what it's going to do
is it's going to make you consistent
about your timing on your stalls you're
going to be able to hit them right in
time with the music which is going to
have such an amazing impact on the
musicality of your spinning but wait he
says there's more so thus far the demo
that I've been giving you has been
exclusively using just my one hand but
hey you got two of those and you tend to
use both of those when you're spinning
poi so you can actually use the same
exercise going through all the different
timing and Direction modes with your
Poise stalls in order to get yourself
used to performing all of these stalls
in time with the music so let me show
you what that's going to look like we're
going to start off with together same
[Music]
6 5 6 7
[Applause]
so that was together same let's try
doing it together
[Music]
opposites
and now in Split time
[Music]
[Applause]
opposites
cool and finally in Split Time same
direction
pretty cool huh so I'm actually really
enjoying doing this exercise now as kind
of a warm-up whenever I pick up my POI
just as a quick way to get my body
attuned to the music and moving in time
with it sooner rather than later it's a
really fun drill and I hope you noticed
that as I was getting more into it I was
grooving out a little bit more it's
pretty cool like that so try this drill
out for yourself and see if it helps you
improve the musicality of your own
spinning I would love to see what the
impact of this is out in the world if
you do this drill and you're happy with
the results please do me a favor and
post a video of yourself doing it online
and tag me I am drexfactor on YouTube
and Instagram in Tik Tok and I would
love to see your hard work and if you'd
like to help more people discover this
drill please make sure to like comment
share and subscribe it helps other
people find the video and it helps my
channel grow so everybody wins thanks in
[Music]
advance
real quick before you head out I just
want to give a quick shout out to my
patreon supporters without whom this
video would not exist in particular I'd
love to give a shout out to my flow
patrons who are listed on screen over
here right now thank you all you're
wonderful and awesome if you like seeing
videos like this and you like seeing
free educational materials available for
PO on the Internet please help me
continue to make them by signing up to
support these efforts over on patreon
you can do that over at
patreon.com direct Factor poy every
dollar contributed there helps make it
possible for me to keep on doing this so
go sign up there please and thank you
need a refresher on the theory behind
the stall box as well as how exactly to
go about doing that drill I got you
covered I'll leave a link to that video
down in the description as well as up on
screen thank you so much for watching
please make sure to get out and flow
today and I'll see the new video real
soon take care now peace